liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz zu unser nun schon
fast traditionellen wöchentlichen
pressekonferenz zur wohnanlage dazu
begrüße ich ganz herzlich
bundesgesundheitsministerin jens spahn
hat sich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz der nehmer platz
genommen professor dr lothar wieler
präsident des robert koch instituts und
ganz außen hat platz genommen dr lisa
federle sie ist leitende notärztin und
pandemie beauftragte der stadt tübingen
und damit eine vertretung des
sogenannten thüringer weg ersparen sie
haben das wort bitte schön
er liebe frau federle meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren zwei monate
nach beginn der impfkampagne können wir
erste erfolge verzeichnen fast alle
bewohnerinnen und bewohner von alten-
und pflegeheim haben inzwischen ein
erstes impfangebot bekommen viele sind
auch schon zwei kämpft und die
allermeisten und das ist das besonders
ermutigende haben dieses angebot auch
angenommen
mehr als 40 prozent der eingesetzten
impfdosen bisher wurden über 80 jährigen
verabreicht in einigen bundesländern
sind schon die mehrheit der über
80-jährigen geimpft das zeigt wirkung
das risiko an krebs zu erkranken hat
sich für unsere höchst betagten
bürgerinnen und bürger deutlich
reduziert die sieben tage incidents lag
in der altersgruppe der über 80-jährigen
anfang februar noch bei fast 200
inzwischen ist sie bei immer noch zu
hoch aber nur noch 70 und vor allem das
was wir einen überproportionalen
infektionsgeschehen über viel zu lange
zeit bei dem besonders älteren gesehen
haben dass nähert sich grad im schnitt
an und wo ist meine vermutung wird dann
auch unterdurchschnittlich werten das
zeigt unsere strategie diejenigen zuerst
hin zu impfen
die besonders verwundbar sind für diesen
besonderes risiko gibt für einen
schweren schwersten oder gar tödlichen
verlauf diese strategie geht auf das ist
aufwendiger das dauert länger zu beginn
aber es rettet leben
auch sonst gewinnt die impfkampagne
anfahrt
stand heute also ist gestern abend 5 7
millionen impfungen in deutschland
viereinhalb prozent der bevölkerung sind
geimpft mit einer erstimpfung über zwei
prozent mit einer zweit impfung bereits
160000 impfungen am tag in den letzten
zwei tagen das waren die zwei
höchststände die wir bisher hatten bis
ende kommender woche werden wir
voraussichtlich insgesamt ist andy und
über 11 millionen impfdosen an die
länder ausgeliefert haben wir sehen
absehbar dass einige der länder auch an
kapazitätsgrenzen kommen ist auch jetzt
auf notwendig ist zusätzliche
kapazitäten aufzubauen noch liegt zu
viel impfstoff im kühlschrank auch das
muss an fahrt weiter gewinnen
einige länder haben unsere mich daher
gebeten dass wir in der info ordnung
ausdrücklich regeln dass sie auch
arztpraxen beauftragen können das werden
wir zeitnah ausdrücklich regeln und auch
vergütungen für die ärzte vor sinne ist
der erste schritt jetzt richtig
auseinander zu halten der erste schritt
ist die länder können wie es einige ja
auch schon begonnen haben in ihren
konzepten arztpraxen beauftragen etwa
bei personen mit vorerkrankungen
impfungen vorzunehmen das sind dann
ausgewählte praxen onkologischen praxen
zum beispiel in einigen bundesländern
für die krebspatienten der nächste
schritt
doch der wird absehbar notwendig werden
angesichts der steigenden mengen ist es
dann bald ist möglich die arztpraxen
insgesamt regelhaft in die impfkampagne
mit einzubeziehen wir sehen mit den
steigenden mengen die wir erwarten
dürfen wenn wir jetzt auch die ersten
hoffentlich bald ersten lieferdaten
aller hersteller haben auch für den
april können wir dann gut und besser
abschätzen wann der richtige moment ist
zusätzlich zu den impfzentren der länder
dann auch die arztpraxen mit
einzubeziehen wir sind dafür
konzeptionell natürlich schon im
gespräch in der vorbereitung das braucht
ja dann auch eine verordnung ergänzung
als grundlage dazu im gespräch mit den
ländern mit den ärzten mit den apotheken
und den großhändlern ich will das noch
mal kurz beschreiben es ist eine
komplexe aufgabe ist muss ja dann der
impfstoff sozusagen zentral
über die regulären wege das ist ja bei
grippe oder anderen impfstoffen auch so
in die über die apotheken über den
sprechstundenbedarf so heißt das
fachlich in die arztpraxen das sind
eingespielte logistik wege aber es ist
eben etwas anders in der pandemie als
sonst und deswegen bereiten wir das
gerade gut vor bis hin natürlich zur
frage der vergütung impfen mit den weg
aus der pandemie
es wird gleichwohl kein spaziergang die
mutationen machen diesen weg
beschwerlich und beschwerlicher wir
werden dabei lernen müssen auf diesem
weg mit diesem virus zu leben
zusätzliche sicherheit auf diesen
beschwerlichen weg kann uns dabei
verstärktes testen geben und auch da
gibt es positive nachrichten es gibt
mittlerweile genug schnelltests auf dem
markt um die viel breiter anzubieten als
bisher
mit der zulassung von selbst oder eigene
tests erhalten wir ein weiteres
instrument für den pandemie
werkzeugkasten beide testen schnelltests
und selbsttests geben dem einzelnen mehr
trittsicherheit in dieser schwierigen
phase der pandemie für den einsetzte
test brauchen wir deshalb praktikable
alltagstaugliche lösungen schnelltests
also die die wir schon kennen können uns
helfen mehr sicherheit im alltag zu
bekommen beim pflegeheim besucht oder
auch beim reisen
sie machen vor allem da auch viel sinn
wo es eine bestätigung einen nachweis
durch einen dritten über das
testergebnis braucht für die nächsten
stunden für das etwa beim reisen was man
vorhat mittlerweile eben deutlich mehr
verfügbar können schnelltests teil
unserer weiteren strategie sein wenn wir
sie kostenlos und niedrig stelle ich
niedrigschwellig anbieten als bürger
test sowie in tübingen frau dr federn
und das team in tübingen das hier machen
und wo ja gezeigt wird gelebt wird was
organisationskraft pragmatismus
kreativität vor ort eben dann für einen
unterschied machen können mit diesem
instrument der schnelltest die
selbsttests dagegen oder hingegen können
sicherheit geben für konkrete
situationen wenn man sich für eine
längere zeit im geschlossenen raum mit
anderen menschen aufhalten will
als selbst test unter aufsicht
möglicherweise vor
in der perspektive jetzt mal etwas
weiter voraus gedacht vor einem konzert
oder restaurantbesuch oder auch in
selbstverantwortung zu hause etwa bei
einem familientreffen
ich bin davon überzeugt dass selbst
schon sehr bald auch
selbstverständlicher teil unseres
alltags sein werden erhältlich an vielen
stellen im handel kostengünstig und
routiniert eingesetzt das wird sich
jetzt entwickeln das wird nicht gleich
nächste woche voll umfänglich zu sein
aber über einige wochen werden wir diese
entwicklung sehr wichtig für beide tests
ist der hinweis gegeben sicherheit
zusätzliche sicherheit aber keine
hundertprozentige sicherheit
ein negativer test bedeutet nicht dass
man dann nicht mehr vorsichtig sein muss
und ein positiver test ist nichts
anderes als die aufforderung das
ergebnis noch einmal ärztlich zu
überprüfen der pcr test der labortest
bleibt der goldstandard abschließend
diese pandemie hat uns allen viel
abverlangt und sie tut es noch
wir werden nächste woche mit den ländern
darüber beraten wie wir in unserer phase
der pandemie die richtige balance finden
für das was jetzt ansteht das bedürfnis
die notwendigkeit auch aus dem block
daun einen schritt zu gehen der übrigens
ja schon begonnen ist in manchen
debatten immer den eindruck dass wir
nichts passiert kitas schulen an vielen
stellen haben ja schon begonnen und
gleichzeitig behutsam und umsichtig zu
bleiben vorsicht impfen testen das sind
drei wichtige bestandteile für unseren
weiteren weg
danke herr spahn professor wille irgend
tag meine damen und herren wenn wir uns
das infektionsgeschehen in deutschland
anschauen dann sehen wir nach wie vor
einige positive entwicklungen
obwohl es immer noch viele ausbrüche in
alten und pflegeheimen und auch
krankenhäusern gibt nehmen die
fallzahlen bei den über 80-jährigen
weiter das ist wahrscheinlich schon ein
effekt der impfungen auch die zahl der
todesfälle geht zurück werden aber
leider immer noch mehrere hundert
das fälle jeden tag an das robert koch
institut übermittelt
all das zeigt dass die maßnahmen wirken
aber es zeigt vor allem auch dass wir
gemeinsam viel erreichen können wenn wir
weiter wachsam sind bleiben denn das ist
etwas was ich ihnen wirklich an die hand
geben
wir haben es wirklich selber in der hand
durch unser verhalten diese pandemie zu
kontrollieren
wir sehen aber leider auch seit einigen
tagen dass die fallzahlen insgesamt
nicht weiter zurückgehen sie stagnieren
auch die bundes heute sieben tage sind
sie denn es hat sich etwa um die 60
eingependelt ja sie ist sogar leicht
gestiegen wieder und die zahl von kogit
90 patienten auf den intensivstationen
geht zwar insgesamt zurück aber in zwei
bundesländern steigt sie aktuell wieder
das geschehen ist also regional sehr
unterschiedlich in einigen landkreisen
sinkt die sieben tage in zweiter oder
bleibt stabil
in anderen steigt sie aber wieder und
zwar besonders bei jüngeren menschen
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass hier die
besorgniserregende varianten auch eine
rolle spielen auch wenn wir das noch
nicht ganz genau abschätzen können aber
eines ist klar die 117
diese variante breitet sich rasch aus
die variante ist deutlich ansteckender
und sie ist auch noch gefährlicher
und zwar in allen altersgruppen und das
macht die pandemie bekämpfen für uns
alle natürlich nicht leichter
das heißt neben dem positiven
entwicklung seit jahresbeginn sehen sie
nun auch einige deutliche signale einer
trendumkehr
deswegen ist es wichtiger denn je dass
wir alle die maßnahmen weiter konsequent
umsetzen dass wir die verbreitung dieser
viren zumindest eindämmen und
verlangsamen
ansonsten steuern wir in eine weitere in
eine dritte welle hinein
wir alle wollen ja unseren alltag zurück
das ziel habe ich denke ich wir alle
gemeinsam das erreichen wir aber nur
wenn wir jetzt weiter gemeinsam an einem
strang ziehen und die fallzahlen
dauerhaft senken
nur so verhindern wir nämlich
erkrankungen schwere verläufe und auch
todesfälle und das in allen
altersgruppen also auch bei menschen die
vielen von uns persönlich wichtig sind
lassen sie uns deshalb weiter unsere
kontakte auf das allernötigste
beschränken und zwar insbesondere in
innenräumen weil in innenräumen die
infektions gefeiert deutlich höher ist
als draußen
darum sollten wir uns immer an die a h
und l regeln halten abstand halten die
hygieneregeln beachten masken tragen und
von immer möglich in innenräumen zu
lüften bitte und ein punkt der ist mir
auch sehr wichtig schon bei ersten
symptomen einer atemwegsinfektion bitte
bleiben sie zu hause rufen sie eine
arztpraxis an und erbitten dann einen
pcr-test und das mächtigste werkzeug
neben uns selber was wir zurzeit in der
hand haben sind die impfungen wenn immer
uns eine impfung angeboten wird bitte
lassen wir uns impfen die impfungen
schützen und sie sind der direkte
gemeinsame weg aus der pandemie und es
gibt wirklich großartige neue daten aus
anderen ländern die die wirksamkeit
aller bislang zugelassenen impfstoffe
sehr sehr eindeutig belegen also
unabhängig davon bleiben natürlich
unsere ganzen schutzmaßnahmen zunächst
einmal bestehen auch die selbsttests
über die im moment ja sehr viel
diskutiert wird wird unsere maßnahmen zu
ergänzen
sie können sie nicht ersetzen so ein
test bietet nämlich keine gewissheit es
kommt vor dass er nicht erkennen dass
jemand ansteckend ist
zu der erwartung dass man sich für
bestimmte situationen zb frei testen
könnte ein negatives testergebnis ist
eben nicht 100 prozent sicher
es schließt nicht 100 prozentig eine
infektion aus man kann trotzdem
infiziert sein und andere anstecken was
heißt das der test ist tatsächlich eine
momentaufnahme
es kann sein dass wir zum testzeitpunkt
eben nicht ansteckend war aber es ist
kurz darauf vielleicht der fall
das heißt schlussfolgernd auch wenn der
test negativ ist sollten wir uns
unbedingt weiter an die asl regeln
halten
wir können uns danach nicht
schutzlos mit anderen menschen treffen
und fragen sie vielleicht worin liegt
denn der nutzen von selbsttests nun wenn
mehr und breiter getestet wird
dann werden natürlich auch mehr
infektionen entdeckt und sie können auch
schneller gefunden werden und das ist ja
ein entscheidendes werkzeug um diese
partie schnell zu bekämpfen
das infektiöse menschen die andere
anstecken können isoliert wird oder sich
selber isolieren selbst es sind also
keine wunderwaffe aber sind eines von
vielen werkzeugen die in unserem
inzwischen wirklich üppig gefüllten
werkzeugkasten gegen die pandemie
bekämpfung zur verfügung stehen das
mächtigste werkzeug ich sage es bereits
sind aber wir selber das ist unser
verhalten und dazu gehört eben auch dass
wir uns impfen lassen man dauernd er
lasst uns dieses frühe das letzte
frühjahr dieser pandemie
lassen sie es uns klug nutzen die gute
nachricht ist dass wir auch die neuen
besorgniserregende variante durch
konsequente maßnahmen und die h&r regeln
eindämmen können und wir wissen auch
heute dass die impfungen auch bei
infektionen mit diesen
besorgniserregenden varianten das risiko
reduzieren
mit 19 zu erkranken und das ist unser
gemeinsames ziel ein frühjahr mit
möglichst wenig neuerkrankungen und mit
möglichst wenigen krankheitsverläufen
gemeinsam packen wir das an und
gemeinsam gehen wir mit 19 keine chance
hat sich neun pro familia dann dr
federle
meine damen und herren vielen dank herr
nicht verspannt für die einladung ich
freue mich ganz art dass ich hier den
tübinger weg zeigen vorstellen und auch
sie über die notwendigkeit und
sinnhaftigkeit einer umfassenden test
strategie informieren kann
sie haben vorhin gesagt praktikable
lösung
ich glaube dafür stehen wir das wenn sie
wegen praktisch und pragmatisch arbeiten
und zwar schon seit monaten
wir haben schon ganz früh angefangen im
märz letzten jahres offensiv mit einer
pzr
test strategie in den alten und
pflegeheim und haben insassen und
pflegepersonal auch ohne symptome durch
getestet und so frühzeitig
infektionsherde entdeckt und
unkontrollierte ausbreitung verhindert
ich habe damals als ich am anfang april
angefangen habe in stuttgart die
auskunft bekommen wenn sie als
symptomatisch bewohner testen dann
können sie ja foto sozialgericht gehen
für die kosten
gott sei dank hat der minister zwei drei
wochen später dann kamen auf jeden fall
dann das so dass bezahlt wird und dass
das korrektes und wir hatten leider auch
gleich bei dem ersten heim auf der
ersten station 16 positive der
symptomatisch leider sind waren einige
verstorben
jedenfalls haben wir dann regelmäßig
weiter kontrolliert und ab 15 oktober ab
dem die ersten schnelltests auf markt
waren haben wir das intensiviert und
ausgeweitet auf wohl neue gruppen
außerhalb daheim also auch auf die
älteren mitbürger die er zu 90 prozent
noch zu hause leben
wir haben ich habe beim projekt
verwendet wir haben das stille nacht
einsamen macht gelangt und haben
kostenlose schnelltest auf dem
marktplatz angeboten fünf tage die woche
wir hatten bis zu 1000 leuten die an
einem tag kam
ich habe hunderte von anrufen bekommen
und die leute haben sich total bedankt
und gesagt endlich tut jemand auch was
für die alten menschen zu hause weil wir
sind genauso gefährdet und wir wollen
halt auch den enkel zu weihnachten 10
unsere aktion haben wir dann weiter
geführt die läuft immer noch
weil wir gemerkt haben die bedürfnisse
der menschen sind einfach da eine
sicherheit zu haben
februar dieses jahres sind wir dann
damit in die kitas und die schulen mit
notbetreuung gegangen und testen jetzt
zweimal pro woche im präsenzunterricht
und dem vollbetrieb der kitas die lehrer
und betreuer mit stichproben der kinder
das heißt wir haben vor zwei wochen
angefangen die ganzen lehrerein zu
lernen
mit diesen nasalen tests das ist auch
kein problem die dann musst du nur
geschultes personal dafür haben das ist
kein medizinisches personal mehr
wir haben video aufgenommen und die
lehrer machen das jetzt an den schulen
in der regel selber die die das nicht
können oder nicht wollen können zu
unserem arztmobil kommen und wir bieten
den kostenlos die tests weiterhin an
aber auch andere gruppen gewinnen mit
einem systemischen test regime erheblich
an sicherheit so habe ich zum beispiel
vorgestern 40 fahrlehrer für solche
schnelltest so sicher und ihre
fahrschüler geschult die ja wenn es sich
überlegen auf ganze in dem raum eine
stunde im auto zusammen sitzen ja und
die zeit miteinander verbringen
dies ist natürlich auch auf betriebe
oder auch die polizei und andere
einheiten und winter institutionen
übertragbar
wir haben auch die erfahrung gemacht
wenn man 80 millionen einwohner in
deutschland
es werden nicht 80 millionen zum
schnelltest das ist quatsch bei uns
werden die umsonst angeboten zeit
sechsundzwanzigster november und das hat
sich eingependelt das regelmäßig
zwischen 150 bis 200 leuten kommen
das heißt sie sind haben uns nicht nur
die bude eingerannt das war nur über
weihnachten
sie müssen aber überlegen es gibt
genügend leute in berufen wie die zu
hause arbeiten im home office mit
mundschutz dann einkaufen gehen die
müssen sich nicht jeden zweiten tag
schnell testen das unsinn
aber wie gesagt das beispiel mit den
fahrlehrern oder aber jetzt mit auch mit
den schirm
ich habe den unseren oberbürgermeister
angerufen und habe ihm gesagt das machen
die friseur mädel jetzt auf und es soll
doch mal anrufen und fragen ob die nicht
einverstanden sind dass wir die
regelmäßig testen und eben den besucher
zum friseur der hinkommt auch und dann
auch eine statistik führen und mal
schauen was passiert da eigentlich ja
ist es überhaupt so gefährlich zum
friseur zu gehen oder nicht und bin ich
geschützt
wir haben nie auf die bundes- oder die
landespolitik
tig gewartet die kosten haben wir
zunächst mit spenden finanziert später
hat uns das landratsamt und die kommunen
mitfinanziert
und jetzt wird sehr kurze dank unter
danke ich ihnen von herzen haus waren
von dem bund übernommen weil es seit
monaten für die die schnelltests kämpfe
und überzeugt bin das ist eine ganz
wichtige strategie ist ja mit dieser
strategie waren wir einer der ersten
kreise die jetzt seit vier wochen die
instanz unter 50 haben teilweise auch
unter 35 gedrückt haben
inzwischen haben über 25 kommunen und
kreise in baden württemberg aber auch in
bayern und hessen unserem modell eins zu
eins übernommen und die tübinger
erfahrung sind auch in das gestern von
der landesregierung baden-württemberg
zum zur zur bund länder sitzung
vorgelegte initiativ papier zur
begrenzten öffnung von gastronomie
handel und kultur eingeflossen
warum ist eine umfassende strategie eine
tragende säule in der pandemie
bekämpfung testen ist neben den lockdown
maßnahmen eine effektive prävention
gegen die ausbreitung desinfektions
geschehens wir haben seit november
mindestens 20.000 schnelltest gemacht
bei asymptomatischen menschen also das
waren keine die zu denen ins heim
gegangen sind sondern nach hause zur
großmutter wollten oder die nachbarin
die zum kaffee zum vater wollte oder
jemand der einfach irgendwie angst hatte
und wir haben bei den 20.000 tests die
wie gesagt symptomlos haben wir haben
noch andere institutionen wie fieber
ambulanz wo die leute getestet werden
mit symptomen haben wir 350 positiv
heraus gefunden
und die haben wir natürlich zum pc js
geschichte nach hause in quarantäne und
die kunden niemanden mehr anstecken
das waren alles leute die auch er
erschrocken waren über ihren test also
wenn ich mich symptomlos anlasslos teste
weil ich eigentlich irgendwo hingehen
will dann rechne ich auch nicht
unbedingt mit dem positiven ergebnis das
heißt wir hatten leute darunter und das
ist meine erfahren deswegen
etwas zurückhaltend mit den selbst fest
da muss man gut aufklären wenn man das
macht weil die leute die bei uns dann
ein positives ergebnis bekommen haben
die waren teilweise ende doch völlig
geschockt oder es gab auch welche die
gesagt haben das kann nicht sein das ist
unmöglich ich bin ich spüre ja nicht ich
mag das nicht
also wenn man selber testet und niemand
sich selbst testet und niemand dabei hat
er das kontrolliert muss man zumindest
vorher die leute gut aufklären und noch
einmal auch anführen was das bedeutet
das ist schon auch eine verantwortung
testen ist unverzichtbar als
flankierende maßnahme für öffnungs
aktivitäten wie wir das in den heim in
den schulen und kitas schon praktizieren
und die das aus meiner sicht für weitere
öffnung von kultur und sport gastronomie
und handel zwingend notwendig werden
sollte
wenn wir nicht mit wumms in eine dritte
welle rauschen wollen das bedeutet wir
müssen wirklich schauen dass wir die
menschen sensibilisieren die menschen
aufklären die menschen mitnehmen und zum
testen bringen das muss quasi wie
zähneputzen jeden tag passieren können
ohne groß darüber nachzudenken aus dem
effeff und aber auch geschult und
angenommen
testen ist auch ein probates mittel um
die ohnmacht und angstgefühle der
bürgerinnen und bürger mindestens
abzumildern und das kann ich ihnen sagen
ich war er es vom wieder in einen
dreistündigen interview menschen anrufen
konnten bürger aus baden württemberg und
ich habe 60 leute am telefon und die
meisten hatten wirklich angst und panik
und hatten erste nicht viele fragen gut
testen schafft nicht das virus aus der
welt aber hilft mit das
infektionsgeschehen unter kontrolle zu
halten solange nicht durch geimpft ist
und es hilft öffnungs perspektiven zu
entwickeln und zu realisieren die aus
medizinischer sicht sonst nicht zu
vertreten werden deswegen begrüße ich
ganz besonders ihre initiative herr
minister sparen kostenfreie tests für
alle zu ermöglichen und hoffe und
unterstütze für eine ganz schnelle
umsetzung und ich glaube dass das auch
so schnell wie möglich passieren sollte
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit und
ich
unsere fragen gibt herzlichen dank für
die eingangs statement dann kommen wir
zu fragen leider funktioniert unser
online frage tool gerade nicht
nicht wir haben es auch noch nicht zum
laufen gekommen das tut mir leid ist
fragen am besten jetzt an die adresse
der bundespressekonferenz wir versuchen
das dann noch einzubauen ansonsten für
die kollegen hier im saal bitte ich an
die sich an die regeln zu halten eine
frage eine nachfrage die erste attacke
ritt bitte kommt können wir das ans ende
zu schieben weil ich ganz gerne die
fragen erst mal corona abarbeiten möchte
dann fragen sie also gerade in der
anfangsphase der pandemie haben auch
zahlreiche abgeordnete des bundestages
übrigens aller parlamente uns hinweise
gegeben an das bundesministerium für
gesundheit über angebote die sie
erreichen haben sie uns weitergeleitet
ich würde gefüllt sagen jeden tag
hunderte es kam von bürgerinnen und
bürger es kam zum teil von denen dienen
angebot machen wollten selbst und es kam
auch von vielen bürgermeister landräte
also wirklich weil alle ihr gs gefühl
hat wir müssen jetzt dringend masken
haben und jedes angebot weitergeleitet
haben
wir haben dafür ein verfahren aufgesetzt
alles was auch mich was die weil ich
natürlich durch den bundestag
durch die kolleginnen und kollegen auch
viel dann direkt erhalten habe immer
weitergeleitet an die kolleginnen und
kollegen
beschaffung starb eingerichtet
federführend durch unsere ministerium in
der bundesregierung und an unserem
betriebsführer und es gab dann relativ
bald ein sehr eingespieltes verfahren
wie damit umzugehen ist
wie die zahlungsmodalitäten bewertet
werden übrigens vor allem auch die
zahlungsmodalitäten nicht wenige wollten
damals sehr umfangreich vorkasse und all
diese dinge sind eben geprüft worden ob
das annehmbar ist oder nicht
und daneben den entsprechenden wegen
entschieden worden und das ist auch bei
angeboten die über herrn doktor nüßlein
angegangen sind genau so passiert
nach meinem kenntnisstand nein natürlich
schauen die kolleginnen und kollegen
aber nach allem was ich jetzt sagen kann
ist dass vom ablauf her genau so
gelaufen wie sonst auch aber ich will
natürlich jetzt kollegen steigen jetzt
sozusagen noch einmal ins archiv
natürlich weil ja auch fragen aus glaube
ich auch dieser runde schon bei uns
eingegangen sind und die werden
natürlich beantworten
aber das ging jetzt innerhalb von zwölf
stunden nicht alles aber nach allem was
ich ihnen sagen kann nach meinem
wissensstand nach meiner erinnerung nach
der ersten rücksprache sind die dinge
genau so behandelt worden
wie alle anderen auch
[Musik]
zudem kann sich herr professor wieder
was eigentlich nur eingangs eines sagen
es wird der 1 passieren wenn wir jetzt
deutlich mehr schnelltests und
möglicherweise selbst tests haben wo
unsere empfehlung ist dass die pcr
bestätigt werden sollten bei einer
positiv testung jetzt die pcr kapazität
denke ich wenn man mal anfängt zu
rechnen dann schon auch deutlich genutzt
werden in der zukunft aber zu einem
internationalen für sein ja also ich
habe die frage so verstanden dass sie
über die genomsequenzierung sprechen
nicht über pcr test oder weil die
ergebnisse der alle publiziert und
öffentlich bekannt sie meinen die daten
die man hochlädt in eine bestimmte
datenbank ja also diese datenbank die
wir nutzen heißt gezählt das ist eine
datenbank die ist unheimlich hilfreich
da sind hunderttausende von sequenzen
drin und es gibt ein bestimmtes
prozedere das prozedere hat unter
anderem auch mit datenschutz aspekten zu
tun
man muss bestimmte metadaten mit
hochladen und diese metadaten die
brauchen wir das heißt also sag mal
metadaten also ein gewisser anteil der
postleitzahl geschlecht alter oder so
was manche von diesen metadaten ich weiß
nicht genau welche im detail doch drin
sind sind natürlich alle immer
datenschutzrelevant und es gibt zum
einen anforderung von gis eher etwas für
diese metadaten mit liefern müssen und
wir kriegen noch nicht alle metadaten
von denen die uns die sequenzen liefern
das hat einerseits technische probleme
die wir lösen und es hat andererseits
eben die die den aspekt dass wir eben
von manchen sequenzieren den laboren die
gar nicht bekommen
und ohne diese daten können wir beides
nicht hochladen wir haben damit
gesprochen letzte woche wir lösen das
jetzt
denke ich ganz pragmatisch aber sie
können dazu davon ausgehen dass wir so
schnell wie möglich alle diese daten
hochladen es ist also nicht so dass wir
diese daten nicht herausgeben möchte
sondern es gibt momentan einfach ein
paar herausforderungen die wir auch
schneller als gestern als heute schon
gelöst hätte rinke sind der gleich zwei
themen zum 1
frage der impfdosen die noch veränderbar
sind sozusagen schon ausgeliefert sind
ist auch wirklich die zahlen heute
morgen nehme mein eindruck dass das vor
allem auch was zu tun hat sozusagen mit
mit der organisation mit der
terminvergabe bis das alles auch stärker
angelaufen ist in vielen bundesländern
klar die diskussion kennen wir auch es
mag den einen oder anderen geben der den
das angebot nicht annimmt wo wir
unbedingt dazu raten dieser impfstoff
ist sicher und wirksam schützt man
schützt sich und andere
wie alle beiden anderen impfstoffe auch
ist auch anzunehmen
aber es gibt ja hinreichend viele schon
in der presse priorisierung gruppe zwei
menschen mit vorerkrankungen polizisten
und polizisten einsatzkräfte kita
grundschullehrerinnen und -lehrer
medizin medizinisches personal jenseits
der intensivstation also wir haben jetzt
in der ersten periode gruppe diejenigen
gehabt die auch infektionsrisiko haben
etwa weil sie eben mit patienten gehen
jetzt können alle beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen schritt für schritt
geimpft werden also es gibt ausreichend
bürgerinnen und bürger da bin ich sehr
sicher die das angebot auch in der prior
gruppe 2 annehmen werden das muss jetzt
nur und das scheint mir im moment eher
das thema zu sein
ankommen das angebot und da sind wir
auch im engen austausch mit den ländern
dass das deutlich an fahrt
die zweitimpfung astra zenica ist dem
fohlen von der ständigen impfkommission
zwischen neun und zwölf wochen zu machen
es gibt daten
ich glaube auch aus schottland aber auch
aus anderen bereichen wo wir sehen wo
auch die stiko ich gebeten habe sich das
nochmal anzuschauen
das zwölf wochen zu einer höheren
wirksamkeit führt als neun wir wussten
schon vorher 9 führt zu einer deutlich
höheren als sechs wochen abstand und
insofern wird man sicherlich in dem
dichten noch mal beraten ob man eher im
vorderen teil von neun bis zwölf wochen
die zweite impfung macht oder am
hinteren ende und wir haben zudem auch
sehr bewusst entschieden die besonders
gefährdet und jetzt in der priorisierung
schrubbe 1 und 2 mindestens auch mit
beiden impfungen zu impfen
bevor nicht auch weitere daten vorliegen
also auch das muss man jetzt auswerten
auch darum habe ich die ständige
impfkommission andere gebeten die daten
zu beyond eck moderner astra zenica wie
viel schutz ist wie lange das ist ja das
entscheidende
nach der erstimpfung da und macht das
einen unterschied ob ich 50 30 oder 80
jährige impfe für die frage was nach dem
ersten impfen schon an schutz da ist ja
ich kann da gar nicht viel ergänzen ich
möchte nur ein zwei gänge vielleicht
noch anmerken ist natürlich klar dass
wir so viele menschen wie möglich impfen
wollen und dazu natürlich logistisch und
klügsten vorgehen müssen und dazu ist
natürlich auch so wenn jetzt sogar eine
zweitimpfung nach zwölf wochen einen
höheren wirksamkeit sogar hat als er
neun wochen dann kann man natürlich noch
mehr menschen auch impfen
wenn man nämlich drei wochen die zweite
impfung quasi aus setzt das ist
doppelter gewinn sozusagen das ist eine
großartige nachricht
aber die die aus meiner sicht jetzt in
dieser woche die wirklich absolut
überragende nachricht die die mich
persönlich sehr sehr glücklich gemacht
hat ist wir bekommen natürlich immer
mehr informationen von den ländern die
sehr viel geimpft haben das ist
insbesondere vereinigtes königreich
schottland wurde angesprochen israel
und sie wissen vielleicht dass israel ja
sehr intensiv daten ergeben kann dort
werden die daten ja auch sehr sehr
direkt den entsprechenden firmen zur
verfügung gestellt so dass man ganz
schnell effektivität studien machen
kannst aber es gibt eine zahl die uns
wirklich sehr begeistert hat diese woche
und zwar in schottland als nur einen
zahl um ihn zu nennen
in schottland hat man etwa 500.000
menschen geimpft und man hat dann
verglichen mit astrazeneca als auch mit
mit g/on tag wenn ich richtig mit
biontech und man hat dann einfach
verglichen epidemiologisch eine eine
stichprobe von anderen 500.000 menschen
die infiziert wurden bzw
die aber nicht geimpft vor allem man hat
gesehen dass dieser astrazeneca
impfstoff tatsächlich die quote von
hospitalisierungen und 94 prozent
reduzieren das ist fantastisch das heißt
also dieser impfstoff ist wirklich sehr
sehr wirksam und dass der impfstoff von
manchen nicht angenommen wird das hören
wir das ist einfach fachlich sachlich
nicht gerechtfertigt was gehören ist und
dass das weiß man ja auch durch die
zulassungsunterlagen das wurde auch
immer kommuniziert
etwa jeder zweite der den impfstoff
bekommt kriegt kopfschmerzen oder auch
fieber für zwei drei tage das ist eine
dieser impfnebenwirkungen aber das ist
ein zeichen dass eben diese impfstoff
sehr stark wirkt und das scheint mir von
den gesprächen die ich habe dass das
etwas ist wo leute scheinbar deshalb
eine zurückhaltung haben aber besser ein
zwei tage kopfschmerzen als diese
verdammte krankheit zu kriegen ja um das
noch mal klar zu sagen
diese stoffe die wir zugelassen haben
sind alle hoch wirksam und ich wäre aber
nichts glücklicher wenn ich selber bald
diesen astrazeneca im stoff genießen
dürfen
ich habe eine weitere frage an sie
professor wieder von kollegen konnten
von zdf sie haben gerade noch einmal
betont dass bei 117 ansteckender und
gefährlicher ist können sie das
quantifizieren welche
forschungsergebnisse liegen dazu
inzwischen vor einer ansteckung zu
schweren verläufen beziehungsweise der
mortalitätsrate also die daten die auf
die wir uns beziehen sind alles garten
bislang aus dem vereinigten königreich
weil
ort dieses virus ja unlängst untersucht
ist und daher auch am besten bekannt ist
und die briten auch wirklich sehr sehr
transparent immer wieder berichten auf
den websites der agentur der der
staatlichen einrichtung aber wir sind
natürlich auch ständig quasi wöchentlich
in gesprächen damit das eine ist es gibt
ja klare daten die gibt es aber
bezüglich übertragbarkeit aus dänemark
holland dass man den erwert berechnet er
liegt ungefähr um faktor 50 prozent
höher es gibt sogar zahlen 70 prozent
höher
also der ist deutlich höher das heißt
also da ist dann ist man schnell in und
exponentiellen wachstum da gibt es eine
reihe daten aus verschiedenen ländern
der punkt mit der höheren gefährlichkeit
es gibt immer klare daten aus dem
vereinigten königreich dass insbesondere
bei hospitalisierten die letalität das
heißt also die sterblichkeit höher ist
bei den patienten die mit b17 infiziert
sind als bei denen die mit den sagen wir
dem regulieren virus betroffen sind das
sind die daten die uns diesbezüglich
vorliegen aus deutschland selber haben
wir bislang solche daten noch nicht in
dem maße dass das können wir noch nicht
sagen wir beobachten das natürlich
intensiv aber umso wichtiger ist es halt
dass wir uns davor schützen dass wir
diese infektion nicht bekommen
also was tatsächlich geschehen wird ist
klar
die menschen die geschützt sind vor der
infektion
die werden natürlich am
infektionsgeschehen nicht mehr so stark
teilhaben wie die anderen
das heißt diejenigen die nicht geimpft
sind auf die wächst quasi der
infektionsdruck und darum ist es so
wichtig dass man auch wenn man locker
und ich glaube das hat frau federle ja
auch noch mal sehr schön klar gemacht
auch wenn man lockert das wird immer
unter schutzmaßnahmen lockert und dass
man zum einen und das betone ich immer
wieder die schutzmaßnahmen weiter lässt
also all die maßnahmen über die wir
reden die wir alle kennen und dass man
zusätzlich eben dann auch noch testet um
schnell zu entdecken dass infektionen
sind so kann man das infektionsgeschehen
unterhalten was aber prinzipiell
passiert das hatte ich ja auch hier
schon mal besprochen
wenn man in so eine pandemie rey nimmt
und wir haben das ist ja der einzige weg
den wir momentan haben dann gibt es
einen druck in sogenannten immun ist
cape druck auf die virus auf die viren
und es ist klar dass sich neue varianten
bilden werden und darum beobachten wir
die ja auch und was wir bisher wissen
ist dass die impfstoffe alle wirken noch
wir sehen dass manche impfstoffe gegen
die variante wir kennen nicht so gut
wirken aber sie sind immer noch wirksam
und wir haben ja diesen großen vorteil
dass wir gerade mit dieser m rna
technologie im stoffe relativ schnell
auch wieder anpassen können man ändert
er nur den bauplan für den impfstoff das
aber nicht zulassungsrelevante und kann
dann relativ schnell neue impfstoffe
machen
das sind wettrennen das wettrennen gegen
die zeit und das virus ist immer
schneller als wir aber wir können das
ihnen beherrschen wenn wir die
infektionszahlen runter darum ist
wirklich meine bitte an alle wenn wir
lockern wenn das entschieden wird
dann mögen sich alle trotzdem bitte so
gut wie möglich schützen
und dann ist dass wir nur eine frage von
wenigen monaten zumindest für unser land
wenn wir dann so viele geimpft haben
dass der impfschutz so weit ist das für
eine
immunität haben und da gibt es auch ein
paar gute nachrichten also wir wissen
inzwischen noch nicht genau wie stark
die virus ausscheidung durch die impfung
reduziert wird aber sie wird reduziert
und wir wissen inzwischen auch das sind
aber nur einzelne berichte dass zum
beispiel frauen die in der
schwangerschaft infiziert wurden dann
aber trotzdem gott sei dank ihrer kinder
unbeschadet haben gebären können dass
die über die muttermilch antikörper auch
oft diese babys übertragen
da gibts nur einzelfälle aber das
natürlich total ermutigendes ergebnis
weil damit ist auch die chance dass für
die grund die militär reichen wirklich
groß also wir haben sie noch nicht
gefunden ja wir haben sie noch nicht
gefunden mehr als 1 7 ist klar
am stärksten vertreten vielleicht noch
mal zu der zu der frage mit der mit der
balance sie haben zu recht gesagt dass
wir die daten auch nicht hochgeladen
haben was mich am meisten ärgert
wahrscheinlich von allen aber ich will
noch mal was sagen wir wir kombinieren
mit dem mit den virus varianten die wir
auch zukünftig finden kombinieren wir
über eine sogenannte typisierung sei die
kombinieren wir die meldedaten über das
deutsche elektronischem welle
informationssystem das heißt wir werden
dann eben wirklich das fällen zuordnen
können dann können wir das potenzial das
klinische potenzial der virus mutation
der natürlich viel schneller sagen das
ist auch so ein technischer schritt und
den datenschutz schritte noch kommt aber
dann werden wir auch viel früher
erkennen in deutschland zum beispiel ob
eine variante vielleicht zu schwereren
krankheitsverläufen führt oder nicht
und das ist eigentlich das wesentliche
ziel auch noch bei der ganzen sequenz
analyse das von neue varianten erkennen
aber das macht nur sinn wenn wir die mit
den epidemiologischen daten verlinken
das ist die große stärke des deutschen
elektronischen informations systems
das sei in den ersten ersten alle
angeschlossen sind um das auch mal zu
erwähnen
fussball
ja das ist tatsächlich auch eine
institution die eigenständig denken kann
das ist so ja wir haben dies auch
ausdruck nicht gewünscht an diesem
konzept haben wir seit märz tschuldigung
dezember gearbeitet weil wir natürlich
daten braucht also es das konzept
versucht ja die aktuelle literatur mit
einzubeziehen sein leben des konzeptes
auch weiter ausgearbeitet wird und wir
haben natürlich für uns ist sehr wichtig
dass wir halbwegs der evidenz haben für
das ein oder andere es gibt nicht für
alles eine evidenz aber für das was für
events finden können das haben wir das
konzert mit eingearbeitet zu setzen
[Musik]
ja das kann ich total verstehen ich sage
in den grund der ist ebenso banal wie
tragisch das website internet team von
uns ist total überlastet und das ein rss
feed ist ja gekommen ja und ich haben
tatsächlich vergessen dass zu twittern
das ist so ebenso trivial wie vielleicht
ist es peinlich aber wenn sie wüssten
wie viele dokumente wir kontinuierlich
überarbeiten jede änderung in der test
strategie zum beispiel sorgte dafür dass
vielleicht wieder zehn andere dokumente
bearbeiten können und in dem fall hat
man eben leider das augenmerk nicht
darauf gesetzt und dann ist das glaube
ich wir hatten letzte woche donnerstag
glaube ich auf die homepage gesetzt
so war es eben vier tage später ich
glaube ich dann ist es dann als
geheimdokument erkannt worden es war
kein garten dokument sondern dafür kann
ich mich nur entschuldigen
michael kurz fällt von der taz fragt an
herrn spahn in vielen bundesländern
scheint noch nicht klar zu sein wie
menschen aus der priorität gruppe 2 ihre
berechtigung nachweisen etwa als
risikopatienten oder als kontaktperson
von pflegebedürftigen
können sie das bestätigen und wann wird
dieses problem gelöst
grundsätzlich sieht die im verordnungen
ja vor dass es ein ärztliches attest
gibt darüber dass eben eine
entsprechende vor erkrankung vorliegt
die zu dieser priorisierten impfung
führt gleich wohl weisen ja viele darauf
hin dass es möglicherweise auch weitere
wege geben kann
nicht wenige länder bitten darum und das
werden wir auch möglich machen dass wir
ihnen ermöglichen mit den krankenkassen
zu kooperieren
ich weiß allerdings um display mal
gleich hier zu machen darauf hin dass
wir bei der versendung von fft zwei
gutscheinen ja gesehen haben dass
krankenkassen abrechnungsdaten man muss
schon sehr genau selektieren wo man sich
wirklich sicher ist dass der- oder
diejenige die jetzt eben angeschrieben
wird als priorisiert berechtigt
tatsächlich auch so zu sagen ja dass die
daten die da sind auch tatsächlich das
richtige bild der vorerkrankung sind
müssen mal so zu formulieren
und natürlich ist der weg dann in die
arztpraxen einer wie gesagt es gibt
bundesländer die arbeiten schon
beispiel mit onkologischen praxen
zusammen um in den praxen krebspatienten
dann auch zu impfen
also dass es dort verschiedene ansätze
gibt aber es ist ohne zweifel so dass
das mit das schwierigste im nachweis ist
das alter nachzuweisen ist leicht
nachzuweisen ob polizisten oder
pflegekraft ist vergleichsweise leicht
erkrankungen brauchen natürlich im
zweifel nach dessen bestätigung
und das macht etwas herausfordernder
wenn man nicht jeden so wie es
eigentlich vorgesehen ist zum arzt für
ein attest schicken will
herr kollege
[Musik]
wir haben ich habe ja auch am mittwoch
im deutschen bundestag noch einmal
deutlich gemacht dass aus meiner aus
unserer sicht diese pandemie in ihrer
ganzen komplexität sich nicht auf eine
zahl reduzieren lässt sich erinnern auch
sehr gut wir vor einem jahr etwa alle ja
nicht einmal zehn monaten über den
nährwert ja sehr intensiv diskutiert
haben
das macht zum beispiel unterschied ob
sie 35 von unten erreichen oder von oben
für die frage der bewertung wie ist der
wert dabei und es macht natürlich einen
unterschied ob sie 35 bei 20 jährigen
haben oder über 80-jährigen also das
natürlich schauen wir immer auch weiter
das ist ja genau das was die
lageberichte des lka es jeden tag tun
sehr umfassend das bild schildern im
gesundheitswesen über das
infektionsgeschehen und anderes mehr
aber die instanzen sind immer ein guter
indikator hinzuschauen
also wann ist ein moment wo man
sozusagen auch spätestens hingeschaut
haben sollten zwar immer die 50er
incidents weil auch die erfahrung aus
dem herbst frühherbst ist ja wenn das
einmal sozusagen gestoßen ist von unten
das dann ist sehr sehr schwer ist das
wieder einzufangen bevor es ganz andere
höhen erreicht hat das
infektionsgeschehen weil sind
exponentiell dann dann weiter geht also
es sind wichtige indikatoren wichtige
bezugspunkte auch durchaus für die frage
von maßnahmen aber eben genauso wichtig
ist es unser haus hat das
robert-koch-institut gesagt das haben
wir immer gesagt das ganze bild zu sehen
und einzuholen die nächste frage frau
[Musik]
wissen sie ich habe im moment den
eindruck wenn ich mir das
infektionsgeschehen der letzten tage
ansehe dass die 35 jetzt noch nicht mal
eben erreicht sind bundesweit sondern
dass dieses virus er gesagt dass wir
wähnten uns auf einem wirklich guten weg
und wir waren ja auch auf einem wirklich
guten weg über drei vier wochen wir
gesehen haben wir die inzidenz sinkt das
infektionsgeschehen sinkt die belastung
fürs gesundheitswesen geringer wird
weniger aktive fälle auf den
intensivstationen wir entspannung
gesehen haben die positive rate bei den
tests runter also alle indikatoren waren
sehr sehr sehr ermutigend dafür dass das
jetzt wahrscheinlich hätte so
weitergehen können
und dann kam unter anderem und
insbesondere die mutation die
veränderung des virus dazu ich weiß noch
sehr gut wie das am vierten advent los
gegen die debatte wember genau
betrachten hat bis dahin diskussionen
und über die frage von mutationen und
mutationen die problematisch sind gar
keine rolle spielen müssen in dem umfang
weil es im vorher nichts und phänomen
war und am vierten advent begann ist das
weiß ich noch sehr genau
morgens 1 der niederlande die einreise
aus dem vereinigten königreich beendet
haben eine diskussion natürlich auch
über welche maßnahmen wir zusätzlich
ergreifen ergreifen müssen und seitdem
merken wir dass das wir noch nicht
abschließend fassen können das ist ja
das problem dass diese mutationen für
das infektionsgeschehen und vor allem
für unseren weiteren weg jetzt ich
möchte noch mal sagen 35 oder 50
wichtige punkte aber kitas und schulen
weil ich manchmal so den debatten in der
einigung habe dass alle sagen hier
passiert ja gar nichts und ihr seid das
alles wie beton ist es ja nicht kitas
und schulen haben gerade in den
allermeisten ländern begonnen und es
gibt kaum eine maßnahme wodurch die eine
entscheidung so viel mehr menschen in
bewegung gesetzt werden jeden tag der
millionen menschen auf dem weg hin und
wie ich zurück und begegnen sich
und ich habe immer gesagt deswegen das
priorisierung dort finde ich richtig für
den ersten schritt und das nicht jetzt
irgendwie zu relativieren
wir müssen jetzt schauen was dieser
schritt macht für das
infektionsgeschehen mit einer mutation
wie sie ist und deswegen finde ich jetzt
im moment die diskussion über 35 kann
soll muss man führen
aber wenn immer auf der iss aktuelle
infektionsgeschehen sehen sehe ich jetzt
noch nicht dass die 35 wirklich sehr
nahe
bundesweit und für viele bundesländer
erreichbar sind
ich empfehle uns allen jedenfalls
größtmögliche umsicht und vorsicht wir
alle spüren dass dieses land meisten im
land wir alle ja irgendwie müde sind
genervt sind davon dass es jetzt schon
so lange geht zwölf monate die nerven
liegen ja auch blanker ich denke das
spürt jeder auch im eigenen umfeld und
wir in der debatte insgesamt aber es
nützte alles nichts
das virus ist da aber müssen damit wir
müssen damit umgehen und das sind kann
ich tatsächlich dafür werben dass diese
balance zwischen diesen bedürfnis dass
ein soziales dass ein wirtschaftlich ist
das ein menschliches ist wirklich gut zu
finden mit der notwendigen umsicht und
vorsicht und wirklich nach jedem schritt
zu schauen was macht das hier gerade mit
dem infektionsgeschehen sie wollten ja
ich möchte es noch mal kurz ergänzen
also es wird ja immer wieder höre ich
das gesagt wird man konzentriere sich
nur auf einen wert
dadurch dass das gesagt wird heißt das
aber noch lange nicht dass dem überhaupt
so ist machen wir haben eine strategie
wir haben einen pandemieplan den haben
wir immer im kopf gehabt wir haben
verschiedene grade habe sehr häufig
erklärt dass es drei große bereiche gibt
an denen wir die krankheiten berechnen
die infektions dynamik die
krankheitslast die auslastung des
gesundheitssystems wir haben es wird
auch immer wieder behauptet wir hätten
keine test strategie wir haben immer
eine test strategie gehabt die haben wir
dann irgendwann ab sommer
nationale test strategie genannt die
steht auf unseren websites
das heißt wir haben immer viele faktoren
berücksichtigt wir geben diesen bericht
seit was gar nicht sagt ich glaube
januar 2020 fast täglich heraus und da
stehen alle möglichen kennzahlen da
stehen auch die tests zahlen drin
ja diese zahlen warum schreiben wir die
denn auf weil wir nur auf die inzidenz
schauen
ich meine wir sind doch diejenigen die
diese krise mit koordinieren durch
unsere empfehlungen es ist doch klar
dass wir nur auf eine zahl geschäumt
haben und das wäre ja auch wirklich sehr
sehr kurzsichtig insofern wäre ich froh
wenn wenn das auch mal wahrgenommen wird
dass es dahinter strategische
überlegungen gibt in denen dann
natürlich jede zahl eine bestimmte
bedeutung hat aber es gibt eben leider
nicht die eine zahl über die wir alle
entscheidungen treffen können eine frage
von jan drebes von rheinischen post
trifft es zu dass sich also dass die
richterin sieht professor wieder treffe
es zu dass das rkw sich dagegen sperrt
astrazeneca für alle priorität gruppen
freizugeben um einen überblick über den
fortschritt des impfens in deutschland
zu behalten und was sagt man es das spar
zu der idee astrazeneca sofort für alle
priorität gruppen freizugeben
also das was dort gefragt wird trifft
nicht zu
es gibt eine stiko empfehlung und auch
dazu nochmal die stiko empfehlung beruht
auf wissenschaftlichen fakten die mutter
darauf dass zu dem zeitpunkt wo der
impfstoff zugelassen wurde es nicht
genügend informationen darüber gesagt
wie gut der impfstoff bei älteren wirkt
wenn ich das richtigen kopfhaut man dass
daten zu 650 menschen über 65
da ist doch schwer zu berechnen
der effekt einer solchen impfung das
heißt es gibt wissenschaftliche daten
und das ist doch schön dass wir in einem
land leben wo nicht jemand nach
gutsherrenart entscheidet wer geimpft
werden soll sondern dass man nach bestem
wissen und gewissen auswertung der
literatur empfehlungen gibt und die
stiko empfehlungen sind natürlich auch
ein lebendes dokument wenn dieses neue
daten ergeben die entsprechend
sattelfest sind
dann wird die stiko natürlich auch ihre
empfehlungen kontinuierlich anpassen
dass ein leben das dokument insofern
kann ich die frage nicht ansatzweise
verstehen
ich kann vielleicht noch hinzufügen weil
die diskussion ja immer wieder auch
erstmal auch nachvollziehbar im ersten
moment aufkommen wir haben stand heute
etwa als trittin kopf habe 1,4 millionen
dosen astra zenica ausgeliefert 1,4
millionen dosen reichen schon bei weitem
nicht um die berechtigten in der
priorisierung gruppe 2 zu impfen und
ihnen ein angebot zu machen und ich
finde es ehrlich gesagt schwer erklärbar
gegenüber menschen mit vorerkrankungen
oder in besonderen beruflichen
risikosituationen in dieser phase der
impfkampagne
wenn wir ihnen jetzt nicht mit diesen
begrenzten impfstoff wir reden nicht
über irgendwie 20 millionen dosen astra
zenica 1,4 millionen dosen aktuell das
mag in vier wochen anders sein aber
stand heute finde ich das dann schwer
erklärbar für menschen mit
vorerkrankungen die seit vielen wochen
hoffnungsvoll auf eine impfung warten
dass dann jetzt auch dort das
entsprechende angebot aus meiner sicht
gemacht werden soll
natürlich vermittelten ist jetzt richtig
natürlich wird das sozusagen mit jedem
schritt auch mit jeder priorisierung
stufe ein stück pragmatischer und
fließender also zu beginn persius
schulvereins war sozusagen eine eine
sehr absolute priorisierung und jetzt
sehen wir schon den übergang zu 2 und
natürlich spätestens dann wenn wir die
arztpraxen sehr umfänglich mit
einbeziehen
ich habe gerade genannt das werden wir
auch so bald ist von den mengen her sinn
macht tun und das wird nicht mehr so
lange hin seien jetzt kein konkretes
datum nennen damit habe ich erfahrung
gemacht aber es wird jedenfalls nicht
mehr allzu lange aus meiner sicht sein
müssen einfach weil die mengen
entsprechend mehr werden in den praxen
wird natürlich auch da die richtige
balance gefunden werden müssen
zwischen pragmatisch und priorisierung
aber die ärzte priorisieren impfungen
übrigens immer schon eine pneumokokken
impfung war auch knapp in den letzten
monaten und das war klar für welche
altersgruppe sie besonders empfohlen ist
und die hat sie auch da wir großes
vertrauen
die ärzte bekommen also kurzum bei 1,4
millionen dosen astra zenica jetzt
irgendwie sind 50 millionen menschen zu
sagen ihr könnt jetzt wird glaube ich
nicht dazu dass ins und die die mit
priorität und guten grund gerade offen
auf eine impfung das akzeptieren würden
und glaube ich auch aus meiner sicht
nicht müssten weil wir eine empfehlung
haben bevor wir zur nächsten frage
kommen muss sich sozial in kleinen
fehler von mir korrigieren
denn ich hatte vorhin gesagt war das
online tool funktioniert können die
fragen als e mails geschickt werden und
habe damit nicht beachtet dass die
pressekonferenz unter anderem phoenix
live übertragen wird insofern wird
kommen jetzt gerade e mails an von
bürgern die fragen stellen worden so war
das natürlich nicht gedacht sondern die
frage möglichkeit besteht natürlich nur
für mitglieder der bundespressekonferenz
und des vbs das nur als vorbemerkung das
können sie dann moderieren ersparen frau
wolfs kempf vom von der ard fragt was
versprechen sich bundesminister sparen
und professor wieder von einem eu-weiten
impfnachweis inwieweit kann dies
rückkehr zu freiheiten und reisen im
sommer ermöglichen
ich finde wir müssen der zwei dinge
unterscheiden zum einen ist die frage
das ist ein auch digitalen impfnachweis
gibt und das zweite ist die frage was
folgt aus einem impfnachweis
grundsätzlich ob er jetzt analog oder
digital ist erster teil wir haben im
corona kabinett am montag entschieden
dass nach der entscheidung des
europäischen rates der januar wenn es
richtig erinnere schon entschieden hat
dass es digitale impf nachweise geben
können soll die auch über einen server
gateway entsprechend eu weit vernetzt
vernetzbare sind haben wir am montag
entschieden dass es auch wir für
deutschland so etwas entwickeln lassen
wollen wir sind gerade im
vergabeverfahren dazu im dringlichkeits
vergabeverfahren dazu falls ja auch
schnell gehen soll um es dann eben ja
innerhalb von
plusminus bitte beachten bis zu zwölf
wochen dann auch verfügbar zu machen
sind natürlich sehr hohe anforderungen
einmal mehr an datenschutz an sicherheit
und ein anderes zu beachten
aber wir stehen diesem projekt als
solchen weil sie erst mal ob sie es
analog oder digital den nachweis haben
die digitale nachweis natürlich leichter
zu händeln ist in bestimmten situationen
sollte andere frage ist und ich finde
die debatte muss wirklich im deutschen
bundestag
das hat jetzt auch als abgeordneter und
bürger breit geführt werden ist ja die
frage was folgt heraus dass ich dem
spiel folgt daraus was oder nicht
und die diskussion findet der stadt und
sie muss auch stattfinden sie hat aber
meine aus meiner sicht nicht per se also
dass eine folgt nicht automatisch aus
dem anderen das eine ist so oder so
jetzt schon der fall jeden anspruch auf
den nachweis bis jetzt analog im jahr
2021 soll es auch digital sein
das andere ist die frage folgt daraus
was und wenn ja was viele ja ich bin ja
seit 8 september bin ich eher eines
komitees der internationalen
gesundheitsvorschriften da hat mich der
generaldirektor der vero beauftragt ein
einwöchige committee zu leiten und in
diesem review committee beobachten wir
und analysieren was an diesen
internationalen gesundheitsvorschriften
vielleicht besser oder schlechter
umgesetzt wurde warum dies oder jenes
besser oder schlechter geklappt hat und
natürlich war da auch über so etwas
gesprochen wie im zertifikate das gibt's
ja übrigens für gelbfieber das ist eine
der initiative karte das haben viele von
ihnen wahrscheinlich auch schon selber
genutzt wenn sie in bestimmte länder
gereicht sind mussten sie gelbfieber
geimpft sein dass das digital zur
verfügung steht ist sinnvoll wäre
natürlich schön wenn solche zertifikate
dann weltweit auch in einer
einheitlichen form zur verfügung
gestellt wurden aber was das dann für
das einzelnen land bedeutet das sehe ich
auch das sind diskussionen die müssen
geführt werden von in den entsprechenden
gremien und dafür den ethikrat wir haben
das parlament wir haben viele
gruppierungen und das wird eine
spannende debatte
und dann wird man sehen was da rauskommt
das vermag ich nicht zu sagen der
digitale impfpass als solcher startet
übrigens weiter
erst am 11 20 22 im rahmen der
elektronischen patientenakte ist das
sozusagen der zeitplan seit jahren also
für alle impfungen die man so haben kein
statt des buches jetzt müssen wir eine
vorübergehende lösung machen aber wir
wollen sie eben möglich machen weil sie
ja auch praktikabel praktikabilität
bietet wir haben noch zwei fragen
vergessen
[Musik]
also das ist richtig das kann ich nur
bestätigen ja ich habe vor mindestens
fünf wochen den sozialminister in baden
württemberg darauf angesprochen ich
hatte die mögliche oder hätte wir hätten
die möglichkeit gehabt 20 millionen
schnelltest sofort zu bekommen mit nur
sichere zusage für baden württemberg und
scheiterte immer bei uns vielleicht auch
ein bisschen am wahlkampf der grad in
baden württemberg geführt wird aber ich
finde das ist vernachlässigt worden ganz
klar und ich glaube wir hätten das schon
viel früher auf die beine stellen müssen
und ich glaube an unserem beispiel in
thüringen sieht man schon was das von
nutzen hat und wir morgens an unserer
bevölkerung und sie sehen es ja auch an
den ganzen gemeinden und kommunen die
das nachmachen
also ich habe das problem dass ich
mittlerweile ich sag jetzt mal wir mal
ich mache das alles ehrenamtlich
das kann nicht so ganz klar sagen aber
ich könnte den großhandel mit tests auf
machen ich habe gestern zu zwei
millionen oder anderthalb millionen
tests bestellt für baden württemberg für
kommunen und deswegen wünsche ich mir so
selig dass das von oben geregelt wird
weil ich mache arbeit
die geht so gar nicht auf dauer zu
machen wenn ich das nur ergänzen darf
mich jetzt nicht der eindruck entsteht
dass der bund jetzt flächendeckend
schafft und organisiert sondern im
gegenteil ich finde gerade das beispiel
tübingen vorneweg aber wenn man
mittlerweile belegen schmack halten
viele andere wo er sich zeigt dass wenn
wir den rahmen setzen die übernahme der
kosten den rechtlichen rahmen für die
nutzung der test übrigens auch den
rahmen dann gesetzt haben dass lehrer
und lehrer sich selbst sozusagen
nachschulungen testen können und anderes
mehr
das da wahnsinnig viel entsteht vor ort
wir müssen die möglichkeiten geben wir
müssen die finanzierung sicherstellen an
tests zu kommen ist auch nicht heute
schon wieder gelesen wir müssen den test
bestehen
also ein schnelltest zu kommen ist im
moment wirklich keine große wenn man
wenn's die apotheke für ein regelt die
kann es auch dann machen für die kommune
oder der großhandel
wir müssen den rahmen setzen aber die
vorstellung die ich gelegentlich so
mitbekomme der bund müsste jetzt im
ganzen land alles organisieren die
beschaffung das testen die sonst was
dass das wird nicht gut gehen können
sondern wir leben doch gerade als
föderaler subsidiärer staat genau von
der kreativität wir müssen sie
freihalten von mir ist erstens
finanziellen themen dabei und im zweifel
bürokratischen themen aber wir setzen
natürlich sehr sehr stark dass das dann
vor ort auch gelebt und umgesetzt wird
und übrigens auch den bedarf der markt
deckt das anders als impfstoffe diese
produkte diese schnelltests wenn die
einmal entwickelt sind sind super
schnell skalierbar wie wir sehen wenn
ich mir überlege oktober hatte ich
november hat sich ministerpräsident
landräte an der strippe hatte gesagt ich
weiß ja wie ein test kommen so knapp
zwei monate später liegen zig millionen
tests zu den deutschen markt im moment
eher auf vorrat bei den herstellern weil
sie nicht abgerufen werden und das
werden wir bei selbsttests auch sehen
nicht sofort aber schon nach einer
überschaubaren zeit da habe ich schon
auch noch vertrauen in die
marktwirtschaft wird da sehr viel
angebot entstehen
das muss nicht immer alles zentral
passieren wir müssen den rahmen setzen
zentral das ist wichtig
trotz enormer sein das kann ich für mich
unterstützen und zwar ist es wirklich so
dass die kommunen und gemeinden bis alle
auch umsonst machen die wollen nur die
tests haben weil die natürlich zu den
preisen keine tests bekommen wie wenn
jetzt man im groß einkaufen braucht ist
ja logisch und deswegen sind wir alle
sehr froh weil das ist sicher umzusetzen
in baden württemberg wird besetzungen
gesetzt dass eben die kommunen und
gemeinden die tests bekommen aber die
arbeiten beispielsweise ehrenamtlich
durchgeführt wird und wir wir machen das
immer mit ehrenamtlichen die ganze zeit
schon und wir rennen die die bude ein
das ist kein witz die leute kommen und
sagen sie seien froh wenn sie in der
krise mit anpacken können wir haben die
ganzen künstler die alle card nicht
arbeiten und so die sind einfach selber
wirklich happy dass sie das gefühl haben
sie
in dem ganzen nicht nur ohnmächtig
ausgeliefert sondern können was tun also
[Musik]
natürlich kann es sein dass wir wir
können alle nicht einschätzen wie die
mutanten sich entwickeln das werden sie
mir bestätigen können wir können davon
wir hoffen natürlich dass das irgendwann
so ausreicht aber wir wissen auch nicht
ob auf dauer der impfstoff tatsächlich
immer noch wirkt je nach mutante und
insofern kann es schon sein dass wir
noch eine weile damit leben müssen und
dann gibt es sicherlich auch leute die
sich nicht impfen lassen
da wird sich das unter umständen dann
auch noch weiter verbreiten aber ganz
klar ist jetzt zwar unabhängig davon ob
wir damit leben müssen oder nicht wir
haben gar keine andere wahl jetzt zu
testen und wenigstens so lange zu testen
bis so viele geimpft sind dass wir sagen
können okay das ist wieder eine andere
situation
wir müssen zum ende kommen weil wir noch
die rede ein kurzer satz ein kurzer satz
noch ich möchte das noch mal klarstellen
das ist ein chaotischer erreger er kommt
aus dem tierreich und der hat viele
wirte das heißt dieses virus das wissen
sie ja kann zum beispiel katzenart
infizieren frettchen was war sich dieses
virus wird nicht mehr verschwinden ja
also falls das immer noch nicht klar
genug gesagt wurde dieses virus wird
nicht mehr verschwinden natürlich werden
wir mit dem virus leben
es wird so sein dass wir durch impfungen
durch immunität die krankheit schwerer
weg bekommen und uns davor schützen aber
wir werden das nicht ausrotten können
das ist eine naive idee an dieses ein
zoo notches virus mit so vielen
verschieden würden können wir nicht
ausrotten also klar werden wieder mit
leben im übrigen haben wir beherrschen
wir kontrollieren im übrigen haben wir
ja auch mit dem masernvirus leben
gelernt und mit vielen anderen uns ganz
gut dann sind wir leider am ende ich
habe nicht alle fragen abarbeiten können
wir uns schön wir uns noch einmal dafür
dass dieses online-tool nicht
funktioniert hat das daran arbeiten wir
noch damit danke ich mich ganz herzlich
bei unseren gästen vor dr federle
professor ila ersparen danke